donc j'ai l'impression que dans cette
émission quoi qu'on dise quoi qu'on
fasse quoi qu'on exprime c'est toujours
le buzz
oui c'est vrai - vous de faire un vrai
gros buzz c'est quoi un truc dont on va
parler demain mais alors par tous ces
coiffes et pourquoi donc
[Applaudissements]
oh
ah ah
alors il ya un problème capillaire
ah non là ça va pas du tout là on y est
là on est devant on dirait que vous avez
joué dans un columbo
on me dira un vieux gars on dirait un
vieux gars dans columbo sans déconner on
aimerait vraiment un jeu fun super jeu
non non si mal à ce que vous avez fait
hier soir boulot il est alerté sur
michel mais j'ai donné pas mal de
plaisir mais je suis déçu quand même à
il avait eu que neuf j'ai eu que neuf
sur dix n'est pas fait que de vous
demander des notes à je demande toujours
une otan parte on non sans les
applaudissements ne suffisent pas il ya
un baiser de cinéma avec le mexicain qui
est derrière regard des mexicains et
pépito merci qui vient tatouage frontale
waters prénom c'est pas possible qu'on
mettra pendant l'émission et il ya un
dîner avec julien lepers vraiment style
moi mais ça sera comme un seul cadeau
elle bah oui quoi c'est très désagréable
pour notre invité de dire que c'est un
sale quart d'heure
[Applaudissements]
oui
les séries c'est une erreur de nos
graphistes s'est trompé de voie là on
s'est trompé de colonne olaya et ce soir
exceptionnellement la salle beau cadeau
et trois cadres a un petit peu moins
bien voilà on va on va passer et et vous
savez la première fois que vous la voyez
deuxième fois 2e fois donc ça a bien
marché
oui oui baballe réclamé tellement vous
êtes allée chez elle n'aura jamais vous
à vous avez un jeu bat chez moi j'invite
et la pga chez moi donc c'est simple il
va merci l'abri chez moi c'était très
sympa les gens l'embrassent merci moi je
vais manger quoi ah non on est passé
directement de serre on sait françoise
soit 11,3 oui eh bien figurez-vous que
formation à ses premiers amours taille
jeune femme que vous avez rencontré un
vendredi soir deux tops 65 à sorèze à
sorèze il est aujourd'hui retraité de
l'éducation nationale vous a jamais
oublié
oui mais non attends c'est pas possible
mathieu
[Applaudissements]
à
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]